[Música]
y deportes hablamos de economía en este
momento aquí nos acompaña Daniela
Blandón como todas las mañanas Daniela
bienvenida buena mañana de jueves ya
estamos diciembre ya diciembre una época
sí de alegría de pues Reconciliación de
reuniones familiares Pero bueno vamos a
hablar de la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos porque yo señales de que podría
moderar el ritmo momento de las tasas de
interés Y eso es bien importante también
porque Acuérdese que uno compra con
tarjeta de crédito en diciembre y todo
lo que diga el presidente de la reserva
Federal nos importa a todos claro los
intereses suban y suben Sí señor pues él
dice que estos aumentos se van a moderar
pero no a acabar y esto es un mensaje
muy importante que no se vayan a acabar
el presidente de la reserva Federal será
un Powell dijo que las tasas de interés
en Estados Unidos pues han venido
subiendo agresivamente precisamente para
controlar la inflación hace un año
rozaba en el 0%, ahora se acercan al 4%
después de salsas consecutivas de tres
cuartos de punto porcentual el mercado
siempre está muy pendiente de lo que
diga la Fed para interpretar entre
líneas lo que dice y pronosticar así sus
próximos movimientos esta vez el
banquero central más influyente del
mundo dijo lo siguiente
la verdad es que el camino que queda por
recorrer para la inflación sigue siendo
muy incierto por el momento dejemos de
lado las previsiones y fijémonos en las
condiciones macroeconómicas que creemos
necesarias para que la inflación baje al
2% con el tiempo para empezar
necesitamos subir los tipos de interés
hasta un nivel lo suficientemente
restrictivo como para que la inflación
vuelva al 2% Como le digo Raúl esta
información Siempre se maneja con pinzas
algunos lo están interpretando como que
habrá tasas más altas de lo esperado y
se van a mantener allí durante un
periodo prolongado hasta que la
inflación se acerque a ese anhelado 2%
anual hoy están casi ocho por ciento
cuatro veces más de lo que esperan pero
la parte esperanzadora del discurso de
paoel es que el aumento en la reunión de
mediados de diciembre podría no ser tan
alto como en los meses anteriores solo
con ese indicio el mercado ya se
ilusionó así es y precisamente ante todo
esto como reaccionaron los mercados Por
qué se ilusiona Porque esa pequeña línea
en la que Power abre las puertas a una
moderación de tasas de interés puso de
fiesta a las bolsas del mundo que suben
su nivel a su nivel más alto desde
agosto con un Wall Street que ganó entre
el 2 y el cinco por ciento casi un 5% en
la jornada previa el futsciende Londres
Se acerca máximos de seis meses esto por
mencionar algún ejemplo al tiempo que el
dólar cae a su menor nivel también desde
agosto y esto por qué se da porque
cuando las tasas suben el dólar se
fortalece y viceversa ante una
expectativa de menores tasas Pues el
dólar se desacelera además de las bolsas
de Asia Pacífico entre otros ganadores
de la jornada también está por ejemplo
el oro que es otro activo Refugio como
el dólar y como el dólar está bajando
Pues todos se van hacia hacia el oro
esto es una dinámica muy buena de la
economía y seguimos en Estados Unidos
pues hablando Estados Unidos que fue con
lo que abrimos nuestro nuestro segmento
de economía porque el presidente francés
emel macron llevará hoy a Joe biden las
quejas de la Unión Europea esto en su
visita a ese país Dani está esperada
visita ya el mandatario galo Tuvo una
primera jornada muy agitada este en este
país se reunió con la vicepresidenta
kamala Harris y con el legisladores a
quienes según asistentes al evento les
habría dicho que la ley de reducción de
inflación promovida por Joe biden es
bastante agresiva Y es que el
descontento por esta ley no solamente es
de parte de los gobiernos europeos
también de las empresas por ejemplo el
presidente ejecutivo del fabricante de
aviones europeos
aseguró que esta ley acelera la
descarbonización pero corre el riesgo de
crear desequilibrio y también injusticia
Porque tanto malestar porque tanta caja
en Europa por esta ley Dani Pues porque
este enorme paquete ofrece subsidios
masivos a quienes adquieran tecnologías
limpias con componentes fabricados en
Estados Unidos uno de tantos ejemplos
los vehículos eléctricos los empresarios
dicen que esto alentaría la inversión en
ese país O sea Estados Unidos a expensas
de Europa y violaría las normas de la
Organización Mundial del Comercio
también que perjudica injustamente a las
empresas no estadounidenses al ponerlas
en desventaja y nos venimos a nuestra
región porque la tasa de desempleo cede
en algunos países de América Latina Raúl
la mayoría de los departamentos de
estadísticas de la región ya entregó
cifras actualizadas a octubre que les
vamos a ver a continuación en Colombia
México en estos dos países la tasa en
estos dos países la tasa se mide
mensualmente allí el desempleo se ubicó
en 9,7% y en 3,3% respectivamente vemos
una gran diferencia entre Colombia y
México el país suramericano por un lado
volvió un dígito y registró 2,4 millones
de personas aptas para trabajar
desocupadas en México la tasa quedó
igual que en el mes anterior y se estima
que hay dos millones de personas sin
empleo Aunque Raúl en estos dos países
más de la mitad del empleo es informal
Dani También tenemos datos de Brasil y
chile Cuál es la diferencia de Brasil y
chile con Colombia México que ellos lo
miden por trimestre móvil quiere decir
los últimos tres meses de los que se
tienen registro esta vez por ejemplo
agosto a octubre en el caso de Brasil
tuvo un desempleo en estos tres meses
del 8,3% en promedio Este es su menor
nivel en casi ocho años y después de que
la pandemia llegara casi a un 15% en
Chile la tasa fue del 8% hasta octubre
mientras que en Brasil cuatro de cada 10
empleados son informales en la nación
austral son menos de tres por cada 10
empleados y que nos trae para finalizar
Este primer bloque económico como cifra
vamos a ver si le gusta la cifra del día
cinco libras esterlinas qué haría con
cinco libras esterlinas bueno comprarme
hoy en día Pues la icónica banda
británica de rock and roll de Rolling
Stones fue impresa Precisamente en una
moneda coleccionable por the royalmente
que es el emisor de valores de Reino
Unido esto con motivo de los 60 años del
grupo con mayores ventas en la historia
de la música británica y aclamado por
muchos no sé si por usted como la mejor
banca banda de rock and roll de todos
los tiempos esta nueva moneda es la
quinta de la serie music Legends después
de otros diseños que han honrado ahí con
los como Queen Elton John David Bowie y
de si bien las mejores cosas de la vida
son gratis como cantaron los Rolling
Stones Precisamente en su versión del
éxito Manny que también es conocida como
That's what it las monedas costarán algo
algunas similares en el sitio web de la
casa de la moneda oscilan entre 15
libras y 465 libras que son como unos
600 dólares por una moneda por una
moneda Pues claro eso
coleccionable Dani como siempre